where do you guys see bitcoin going and
the price going in 2022. since we're an
on-chain analytics company we can take a
slightly different maybe approach
to
what usually people say so
you know
since we are quite good at uh you know
uh finding the supports and resistances
um i think the you know most important
level for bitcoin is 47 right now and i
think uh like um we already posted on
our twitter i think like almost exactly
a month ago on the 16th of november
that uh you know there's two main key
levels for bitcoin that's 57 and 47 and
currently yeah we're at 47 obviously
we're getting some you know uh traction
you know going down to
uh you know lower levels but in general
uh i think yeah if we continue going uh
you know holding 47 we can definitely go
to the upper uh supports what do you
guys think in terms of long term uh with
bitcoin for the 2022 do you think that
we can see you know hundred thousand
dollar price point five hundred thousand
a million uh 20 000 what what's kind of
price action in 2022 over a long longer
period
well it's uh to be honest on chain
analysis company we're not traders not
financial advice this is just well of
course we believe we we're strong
believers in the technology and like the
the one thing that we have to understand
blockchain technology it is superior to
what is currently out there in the
market and there is a finite uh number
of bitcoins out there uh the us
government is printing money like crazy
and there are these fundamental like
very logical reasons to believe that
there is
there is a lot of potential for uh
bitcoin's price appreciation to go up i
mean it's the biggest um crypto asset at
the moment uh so and a lot of people
have belief in it and some people call
it as an alternative uh store of value
and i think the more people wake up to
the to the idea of maybe inflation is
going to happen with fiat markets maybe
you know maybe fiat markets are not as
stable as people
lead us to believe uh i think when that
happens there's gonna be a very much
increased demand for bitcoin and other
crypto assets so i think 2022 will be an
interesting year and so far it has been
it has been quite good because i think
right now crypto has stabilized itself
as
it is a market and if you if you doubt a
two trillion dollar market you know you
should
you should really rethink that
artem let's finish with you last
question do you think that every single
financial institution uh in the world is
going to eventually have to use on-chain
metrics like is this going to become
pervasive throughout the entire
financial system
uh well that's a good question i don't
know the 100 answer to that i can
definitely speculate and you know the
analogy you can make is you know you had
market data originally
and that's what a lot of people use and
for example you have
indicators like rsi or macd or you know
moving average and that's
basically you know it's
free and it's
you know mainstream you could say and
since it just uh no on change just gives
you so much more actionable data much
more actionable than rsi
i mean i think people will go towards uh
value in the future which is on chain
analytics